l'environnement avec les conséquences
très concrètes de la raréfaction de
certaines espèces en l'occurrence il
s'agit d'un secteur notamment d'abeilles
partout sur la planète leur nombre est
en chute libre
or il participe très activement ces
insectes à la pollinisation la
fécondation des plantes
les chercheurs en france par exemple
tire la sonnette d'alarmé
mallory ya ou non josé boulesteix la
moue quand le chercheur devient chasseur
bernard vaissière et spécialiste des
insectes pollinisateurs
il vient de capturer une abeille
charpentières la seule à se nourrir du
nectar de ce jeune est d'espagne est
donc la seule à assurer sa fécondation
en transportant le pollen de fleurs à
fleurs ça nous aide à quantifier
l'abondance et la diversité des
pollinisateurs effectivement avoir des
références pour pouvoir quantifier leur
déclin ou l'évolution de la population
et le constat est inquiétant d'après
l'enquêté menée au niveau européen 30%
des espèces de pollinisateurs sont en
déclin
première concernée les abeilles
domestiques et sauvages vingt mille
espèces dans le monde mais aussi les
bourdeau certains papillons ou
coléoptères or leur rôle est
considérable 80% des espèces végétales
mondiale et 84 % des espèces cultivées
en europe dépendent directement de la
pollinisation par les insectes fruits et
légumes condiments sans les abeilles il
n'y aurait presque que de la pomme de
terre des épinards et des bananes dans
nos assiettes pour certains agriculteurs
leurs rares et actions se fait déjà
sentir
et ces dernières années il ya eu des
manifestations importantes de ce d'éclat
avec par exemple la crise de
pollinisation très réel des amendes
hébergé d'un mendiant californie où on a
dû transporter des colonies d'abeilles
en toute urgence depuis l'est des états
unis l'état de new york jusqu'en
californie
sans compter les conséquences en terme
de biodiversité en cause l'urbanisation
la monoculture qui raréfie l'habitat et
la nourriture des insectes et bien sûr
les pesticides
certes on commence à imaginer des
solutions comme des jachères fleuries
pour repeupler les espèces mais il
faudra bien plus pour inverser la
tendance
b